what's going on everybody and welcome to
a review of the two gigabyte
jetson nano so the two gigabyte nano is
actually the
little brother to the four gigabyte nano
the original one which we also reviewed
on this channel some time ago
the only significant difference is this
has two gigabytes of
ram this one has four the gpu is a 128
core
maxwell gpu and that is the same on both
devices also both devices have
i believe the exact same four core arm
cpu
the other differences that i could see
by looking at least at specifications
online is that the 4 gigabyte nano
apparently has two csi connectors but
when i look at this board
i just see the one so um i don't know
i don't know if this is like an early
board that i happen to get and they
added another connector i don't know
but i only see the one i'm not really
sure you need to
two is kind of cool i guess so you could
run like the two raspberry pi cameras
and so on but if you need more cameras
um you can always use the usb ports uh
so yeah so on this four gigabyte
um again there's just the one csi
connector that i can see
but again that's all you really need i
think um the other difference is this
board is actually powered by usb
c does still have the micro uh there
and also there's i think one fewer
usb ports yeah this one also the four
gigabyte has a display port
i don't see that here this one just has
hdmi
again i don't think that's a big deal at
all
i think most projects aren't going to
need that and if you desperately need a
displayport i think you could just use
hdmi to display port converter i don't
know
so i don't really think it was necessary
so it's kind of cool that they've what
they've done here
really all they've done is kept that
same powerhouse that 128
core maxwell core gpu
and instead just trimmed away some more
things to the dev kit
uh to make it more affordable to people
so this was 99
and this one is 59 and to be honest 59
for that 128 core maxwell cord
gpu that's that's pretty cool i mean
maxwell core
kind of old old architecture but still
quite powerful powerful enough to do uh
things like object detection and so on
and so
actually what we did when we got the
four gigabyte board
was do object detection um
with a usb camera on the board just to
see what kind of
you know specs could we get or what kind
of frames per second basically as a
metric
and then i tested that same exact thing
the exact same program
on the two gigabyte nano and
unsurprisingly got
basically identical results um obviously
the again the only kind of performance
downgrade that we get here
is the ram now two gigabytes of ram is
it's tight i'm not going to lie there uh
but
still uh in practice at least with the
the one test that we ran
um it it still produced identical
results obviously you can also use swap
which i had to do
to build uh some packages on this device
but i
also had to use swap on the four
gigabyte now so
um honestly at least for me it hasn't
made a big difference but again i
i just know in my in my head that two
gigs of ram is
is tight um so so yeah so the board's
actually pretty impressive the only
gripe i have is actually the same gripe
i had with the uh four gigabyte nano
which is the heatsink so i recognize
maybe
i mean well with the gpu i kind of think
especially this gpu i think it's
it's required that they send it with a
heatsink i recognize they've they've
sent it with a heatsink thank you nvidia
but uh
recently i reviewed the xavier nx
dev kit so this is one of the more
pricey dev kits this one's like uh
i want to say 384 core i
can't remember off the top of my head if
it's pascal uh
and then and i think it had 384 uh core
cuda cores and then like 40 something
tensor courses i i can't remember
perfectly um definitely a more pricey
device so
cool it gets a nicer heatsink but i
can't imagine the heatsink and fan
combination is
too expensive again i recognize that
this is supposed to be a
trimmed down device i respect that i
like that goal
of getting cheaper cheaper devices
especially deep learning devices you
literally can do deep learning on this
device it's a 59
device you can do deep learning out of
the box
but you can only do deep learning out of
the box
for about 10 minutes before this device
will
overheat now on the four gigabyte nano
i actually wound up corrupt like
basically it overheated and then like i
don't know it just shut off
and it turned out the sd card got
corrupted i had to redo everything
um at least on this device uh it
it just displayed this message that it
was throttling and
everything else it was like okay
but but that's not good for the hardware
um so
i i wish i wish that they would send it
with
one of these kind of heat sink and fan
combos because this works very well
actually this device stays
within a decent range of temperatures
whereas this device
simply does not you can't use this dev
kit without a fan
and and you can't even dev on it without
a fan i think that's kind of a problem
so i recognize you know if you use in a
project you would just add a fan to it
and blah blah blah but i i think
i think that's the one thing i would
change and just add a fan
just can't be that bad especially
because they're adding
um people were wanting wi-fi
on the board and there is no built-in
wi-fi but apparently they're sending
these out
with wi-fi dongles to everybody and in
my opinion rather than the wi-fi dongle
send the fan we don't actually need not
every project will need wi-fi like for
me
at least in my use case i recognize i'm
not everybody but i just plug in the
cable
and i ssh to the device it's really
simple
and then if i need wi-fi well yeah i've
got wi-fi dongles all over the place
so so if you needed wi-fi you could add
it
but not everybody will need the wi-fi
dongle everyone
will need the fan so anyway i do wish
they added the fan but other than that
i i think everything um i think this
board is really cool i hope nvidia
continues
obviously to make you know cool powerful
dev boards like this one
also the super high-end gpus but i also
kind of like that
nvidia is what i would think now is kind
of
targeting the smaller kind of edge
truly edge devices uh that pretty much
almost everyone can afford to kind of
tinker with and play with
i think that's really cool and bringing
ai to these kind of like smaller cheaper
boards like the raspberry pi
only good things can come from that
getting that in the hands of
as many people as possible i think only
good things can come so
i really like that like i said my only
complaint
get a fan on there i hope the next one i
review has the fan
i was so excited when i saw this this
one
i don't know how much it adds to the
cost um
and and this one's actually kind of
really nice maybe you can make a cheaper
version of it or something i don't know
anyway really like it um i'll put a link
to nvidia's page for this in the
description you can get it off of amazon
and like all the other places it is
currently i believe still in pre-order
right they they ship
late october so i don't even think we
have an i guess an exact
date yet but anyway pretty cool
technology i'm really happy with it um
i gotta come up with i have some small
projects i'd like to do
as as we complete the neural networks
from scratch book
um i've got some small projects and i'd
like to kind of put these little dev
boards
more to use so uh maybe we'll see more
of these
especially this one i feel like it's a
sin to not be using this awesome board
right here so
so stay tuned hopefully we'll have some
content on this if you've got some ideas
that
of projects that you'd like to see with
this uh let me know but i definitely
have some ideas
whizzing around in my head so anyway
that's all for now again
like i said the board releases in late
october for
59 which in my opinion is a steal
just have a fan um you literally could
just like put it on a like a stationary
fan or something
just have a fan but yeah pretty cool
and that's all for now till next time